hey youtubers it's Charlie so this is
gonna be my Gotham episode 19 video I
know it's been off the air for a little
while so I'll try to do like like a
refresher just to remind everyone where
all the characters are it's the
beginning of a two-part arc with Milo
Ventimiglia skater he's playing the ogre
he's a character from the comics so I'll
actually I'll start by explaining who
that is just careful for spoilers from
the episode if you haven't seen it yet
the character is called the ogre but his
real name is Michael Adams he only
appeared once in the comics and he's
kind of a riff on Frankenstein he was a
genetically altered person that killed
the scientists that created him he was
like the last in a line of experiments
after he killed the scientist he ended
up just wandering around the streets of
Gotham kind of the same way Frankenstein
ended up wandering around the
countryside there were actually a couple
of Frankenstein Easter eggs from the
episode I think of it more as like a
Bride of Frankenstein thing because he's
looking for love so the character that
Milo Ventimiglia is playing is more a
riff on what the original comic book
character was based on rather than the
character itself one of the big
Frankenstein Easter eggs was when they
revealed that one of the victims had
been dumped in the river it's a
reference to the original Frankenstein
movie where he's playing with a little
girl and then accidentally throws her in
the river and she drowns in the case of
the show you know until it wasn't an
accident he murdered her but you get the
idea the title of the episode was birds
of prey so you had like a lot of the
main characters preying on other people
you know most notably the ogre preying
on women but you also have Bruce and
Catwoman preying on Reggie the penguin
preying on Tom Maroni and that boyfriend
that he roughed up even fish Mooney
ganging up on the dollmaker
the funny thing is is that most of the
stuff I've read about this episode I
actually think happens during the second
part during next week's episode number
20 since Gotham's been off the air for a
while I'm just gonna take like what
happened in this episode and just do a
refresher for each of the characters
just like update their storylines
starting with Bruce and selina they
actually they find out who the board
member is who's making all these orders
his name is bunderslaw I know that
sounds a little bit strange but he's
being played by Michael Potts who was
the creepy bowtie contract killer on the
wire so I'm actually really interested
in that dynamic even even though I'm not
as big a fan of the little kid detective
scenes I like the idea that Bruce's is
slowly becoming the world's greatest
detective one day at a time but I don't
think they're dark scenes like pushing
Reggie out the window counterbalance the
really dark adult scenes quite as well
so anytime there's like a
lot of Bruce in an episode if you look
the tone of the episode changes in weird
ways one small departure from the comics
is that you know Catwoman is the one to
push Reggie out the window but she's the
one in the comics that helps informs
Bruce's decision to not kill anyone like
Batman has a rule no killing and
Catwoman is a big part of that so onto
the penguin still trying to get rid of
Don Maroni he's not on the outs with
Falcone
but Falcone Maroni have an agreement now
so I think that penguin is just trying
to hedge his bets based on Maroni's
picture on the wall of that bar I think
that is just someplace that he really
likes so the penguin is probably just
going to try and trap him there fish
Mooney of course still trying to escape
the dollmaker I know it seems like she
drunk the kool-aid but this episode
answered most of those questions she
definitely wants out her story was a
nice metaphor for the ogre flashbacks
all the women that the ogre trapped her
storyline in this episode like the way
she escaped is gonna be mirrored I think
by a story in next week's episode I
don't want to talk about it because it
might be spoilery but just remember how
fish Mooney escaped her captor so next
we have Gordon vs. the commissioner
apparently still a pretty big thing even
though it seems like they settled their
differences last time I was a little
taken aback how they brought the
Commissioner back in this episode how he
was running the plot against Gordon
trying to get him to take the ogre case
I think what the Commissioner was
thinking is is that the ogre would take
care of his Gordon problem for him or
they cancel each other out like they'd
kill each other the way they hold him in
actually makes the character seem a lot
weaker than the Commissioner character
he seemed like a much bigger deal
earlier this season there's a TV trope
called villain decay where you start out
with a villain that's really dangerous
really powerful but every subsequent
time they appear they get weaker and
weaker it gets easier and easier for
Heroes to beat them so they become less
of a threat the same thing kind of
happened on arrow with the Deathstroke
character like whenever he came back
after season 2 he was way weaker way
easier to be even Reggie in this episode
seemed way weaker like the like the last
time we saw him meeting with the Wayne
board he seemed like a badass like he
had this grand plan but now it turns out
he's just an addict who was doing a job
and he got pushed out a window by two
little kids I think what's happening is
is that the narrative wants to give the
heroes or the protagonists a win because
the penguin isn't a hero but he is a
protagonist I think it accomplishes that
goal at the expense of good villain
characters there should be a way for the
protagonist
without making the villains seem like
idiots Gotham does plan a lot of the kam
penis of some of the classic Batman
stories but I don't think it's the
writers intention to make the villains
seem silly like they have silly moments
but they're not silly characters so far
one of the few villains I think that
that's held up in terms of threat level
is the dollmaker so they might position
him as the big bat of the season or one
of the big bads that they have multiple
we really don't know about these Wayne
bored people yet but I'll be a little
disappointed if Bruce is able to take
them down all by himself I mean he's a
little kid he needs help
he'd be like Oliver Queen beating
Rochelle ghoul in a simple fight ratio
goal world's greatest assassin he has
more experience than anyone there's no
way you're gonna beat him unless
something is really wrong with him so
I'm hoping that they don't hamstring any
of these big Gotham villains before the
end of the season to make it easier for
Bruce the other characters to beat them
so far the flash which is actually
coming back tonight has done a really
good job of you know maintaining a
certain quality of villain I feel like
the reverse-flash character has been
very consistent here's my big question
for you guys though what do you think of
Milo Ventimiglia character his or her
character so far I'm not a huge fan of
the actor I'll give him a chance that
we'll see in like the second part of
this story if it picks up a little bit
most of you apply know him from heroes I
feel like he started out really awesome
in season one and then just like slowly
got worse like his character just wasn't
that interesting by the end of the
series but I do have high hopes for him
playing a villain on Gotham next week
again and I think we'll get it more of a
deep dive into the ogre so be sure to
subscribe to get that video I already
mentioned most of the Easter eggs in the
episode you know mostly you know
Frankenstein character ogre from the
comics as well as Bride of Frankenstein
stuff you know I actually kind of funny
Easter eggs just as an update because
I'm praying not gonna make a video for
it Constantine seems like it's been
canceled I haven't heard official word
from the showrunner yet but most of the
TV journalists that I follow are saying
they have unofficial confirmation from
the network's I think the character has
high potential to get star on the on the
flash or arrow inside that universe so
I'll talk a little bit more about that
during my flash video tonight so while
you guys wait for that there was
actually a really big ant-man trailer
that I posted a video for yesterday you
can click here to watch that now and you
can click here for all my other Gotham
videos just to catch up thank you so
much watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight
you